because i've noticed i noticed sydney
has also had to deal with i guess
something similar just on like the
opposite end of the spectrum yeah yeah
because she does make content on
covering like the more adult side of
things they just assume that's her only
prediction
they just assume that's her only
personality i remember like like two
weeks ago or something she was just
hanging out she was back in england like
a week before me or something and she
was just went out to hang out uh with
one of her best friends who happened to
be a guy but like
it's just it's just like he's just like
a normal guy right now
and he's not that involved in the anime
community or whatever he's just a guy
and i remember he was just like happy
that he got to see what he one of his
best friends and he posted it on twitter
and i remember just like seeing like the
comment chain of this was just like
it was it was just lntr yeah yeah oh ncr
ncr like oh you know like [ __ ] scary
character all that and and i remember
like because it was eugene right it was
youtube
yeah yeah and i remember i remember
talking to eugene afterwards he was just
like
what is this i like he he was so out of
his perception of like how people act in
his world he was just like what is going
on right now i just posted the picture
just hanging out with sydney right and
and it was yeah it was it was it was so
it was it was so surreal as well because
uh because you know they were they were
just having like a normal hangout you
know and yeah that was pretty much it um
and uh it wasn't like sydney it wasn't
even placed on sydney's account he was
like posting on his personal account as
well
uh his personal account so it was like
all the replies go on his account so you
just yeah yeah it was just really weird
to see i think
people didn't behave your virgin
i think a lot of people forget
that
you know it's not funny
but like not everyone around your life
is you know to do with let's say your
personality online or your work you know
just because you talk about x doesn't
mean like everyone you associate with
and talk to and relate with is you know
understands the same feeling in the same
circle yeah of course of course um and
it's sometimes easy to forget that one
like basically creators have uh creators
have backstories and characters
my friend solely i have her in like a
bunch of my videos but she
outside of that she just does not have a
life on youtube she has like her own
life and she at one point had to make
like a second twitter account right
because she couldn't post anything
without people being like were you with
emily what was emily doing and she was
like i don't i don't know
my life doesn't revolve around her i
remember she got she got super fed up
because one valentine's day she posted a
picture of like burritos she got with
her boyfriend
and they say his
and hers on that yeah she goes oh look
what they wrote on our burritos and we
went to get them right and someone was
like oh did you get burritos with with
emily she's like they say his and hers
like uh and it's valentine's day
obviously it was my boyfriend what are
you talking about oh my gosh
people be walking yeah
yeah so like have you had to like
struggle with
like people you seeing seeing you that
way or have you like tried to like break
the image at all
um no i it just like it's a little
annoying when it happens but i mean i
get it i think it's because it's like i
have a drawn persona and i feel like
people associate like ooh drawings yeah
childlike yeah i also really like cutesy
things so it doesn't surprise me that
people
like perceive me that way yeah i think
it's also that because because of the
community you're in where a lot of like
the story time youtubers are seen as
like the family-friendly kind of like
personality and like kind of branding in
general yes i think uh i think that
plays a part into it as well and
the reason why i don't curse very much
in my videos is uh
because
there have been too many horror stories
i've heard of people like in the
storytime community slaving away over
like a video yeah but they say like one
curse word yeah in like the first i
guess
immediately gets your monetized
of work which yeah totally get right you
put like a few months work into this
video and you say [ __ ] once and you're
like okay income gone it's so strange i
have to say like some really abhorrent
stuff to get demonetised like i can say
like [ __ ] as many times i want it
doesn't get demonetized i mean i it's
never happened maybe it shows like it's
like are you british
maybe
yeah dada said this on the last episode
as well
he doesn't curse because of that as well
yeah which is understandable but it
makes you want to curse more right i'd
want to curse more
like your channel yeah yeah you go ham
on mine dude look at this [ __ ]
[ __ ] goofy ass [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] drawing you should do a [ __ ]
door again you stupid [ __ ]
other people's channels but then people
who watch my stuff will like see it
they're like
the first image like this time like you
drew like you came on my channel and you
were like swearing i remember like a
bunch of comments you were like whoa
emily's really crude in this video and
it's like it's they're not they don't
say i'm crude that's how i normally are
and you're acting like a normal
conversation yeah i don't even think i
was cursing accessories you weren't you
were you said [ __ ] once or twice and
then i was like
we we we get the opposite right like if
we're like doing like a sponsored
content on someone else's channel or
whatever or like you know it's a channel
we don't have questions
they're like oh man he's trying really
hard
he's like you can see the pain popping
in his head
like like on whenever we've done like
interviews or something and our audience
finds it yeah um
we always get comments being like i've
never seen the boys so well spoken in my
life
they're so professional i i shouldn't
say [ __ ] what i sound so much more well
spoken when i don't swear but it's so
boring it's so natural for you though i
feel like swearing is the spice of like
language you know it's like it's like
how much spice do you want inside yeah
keep putting that i just like okay don't
okay stop stop stop kind of stop
it's too spicy i don't know it's it it's
such a
i love swearing and what it does in the
english language it's so powerful and
it's yeah it conveys emotions really
well absolutely and i think that's one
thing i really love about english is
that you can get like such a precise
emotion with the right combination of
swelling yes
i definitely feel that that's one aspect
japanese doesn't have as strong in
english and because they have kuso for
everything because everything is kuso
it's like come on
where's your bell end where's your
knob know what i mean like we've got
like 500 different ways of saying like
the exact same thing yeah all of them
are like slight different shades of
insult yeah why do you think i love
swearing in english because
japanese yeah right right i'm like i
feel i feel so empty when there's no
[ __ ] in japanese i just feel like i'm
just saying in english the sheer level
of creativity and insults in english is
so deep yeah
it just makes me love it like just just
think about how malleable the word [ __ ]
is it's just like it blows my mind
sometimes yeah every language [ __ ] can
be every emotion every scenario all
right yeah [ __ ] exactly yeah yeah yeah
you always say [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'll be like oh we're having noodles
like [ __ ] no way
there's no way this video is not getting
demonetized now yeah
wait is it the first 15 minutes
yeah i think we're good sorry oh no no
it's okay when i when i do curse i just
like cover it with a sensor yeah yeah i
i don't acknowledge the fact that there
are a lot of like younger people
watching me and i don't want to like
make that a habit for them yeah what
sensor do you use do you use like the
quack sensor that like i used the
i think i think i used the windows error
noise oh you do
it's like this
[Music]
that's how you know you're on a gaming
let's play channel yeah yeah yeah right
yeah i just know i normally i don't just
yeah i guess that's why a lot of my
videos get demonetized i don't normally
censor myself yeah but instead of the
anime titties can't be inside
yeah
exactly yeah what were you talking about
before i completely forgot what about
about uh
online audience yeah yeah
like online friends and stuff